[Music]
welcome to the Samuel Leeds podcast and
this week I sit down with a Ricky Mandel
he's quite a character and I think this
is a podcast that you're gonna enjoy so
stay tuned
Ricky Ricky Mandel Samuel Samuel Lee
dude I've had you on my youtube show to
me Tom's blood is my show
people are cussing me out the same why'd
you keep getting this dude on the show
like he gives no value whatsoever Sonny
someone said to me the other day
have you taken over some his YouTube
channel and I was like yeah and I'm
gonna keep on doing the same I love it
so what do you have to say then you're
here now is your time listen we're here
we're just having a chat we're doing
some training stuff actually big message
what's your value piece my value piece
is just do what you want to do in life
and enjoy it yeah you know what people
one of the reasons people respect you so
much is because you've become very
successful in property but also you
speak really well and I've been
literally having you my crash courses
sharing and sharing the story and in all
seriousness people have said to me are
you know threatened by this dude he can
speak better than you on stage but for
me that's a compliment because I'm
thinking if my students can literally
speak on stage control the energy of the
room get people Pumped give content and
value and people are becoming successful
in property now their messaging you yeah
like I used to get those messages I
still do get the messages more than ever
but you're now getting the messages I'm
financially free because of you Rick a
way how does that feel to get those kind
of messages when you've only been in
property yourself less than two years
it's humbling man is hummus it's why
it's why I wanted to speak on stage to
help other people and I think you
shouldn't see as a threat to you because
you don't that train me to speak so
really I know me I'm not found by anyone
oh I know you
of course you're not is the people who
are my competition okay here are the
people people say like oh there's
another training company great yes 0.1%
of people go on training companies to
become financially free the people that
are arguing against are the universities
that can't teach money this year's that
can't teach money the fake teachers is
Robert Kiyosaki would say yeah the banks
that are saying will lend you 20 grand
and holla
we won't lend you 20 and to find invest
but it's a good thing people's are
saying like Oh
to you maybe Ricky as with competition
or is he a fret because you've taught me
well then because it's like if you when
you teach people properly your people
aren't good and proper you have done
your job you talk about to be properly
taught me how to speak and uh you know
I'm getting complements and messages
about both I'm doing well so you've done
your job well yeah you know tell me what
kind of salary it could taking
everything into account I know you do
you do sauce and you got your
intervention your own personal property
portfolio stuff you got stuff that you
doing with your parents the only
developer yeah what kind of what kind of
salary or what kind of amount of money
you expect to be taking this year
everything everything a lot more than
last year
okay how much let me see
oh dude what this is calculation is
bright because you mean it's a big
everything we're looking what I'm
looking at I'm not gonna phone cameras
for my phone now because you've seen my
figures and stuff I'm looking at six
figures six figures this year's you're
so funny there's such an awkwardness in
working-class families around asking
people about their income in this hour
right yeah or their net worth it's like
so taboo and I feel like even you were
uncomfortable when I just asked that
question
yeah why what do you think you think
it's a bad thing or a good thing because
sometimes no there's just one dude who
said to me I think he said one of my
facebook like videos or something and he
commented and he said I'll believe you
when I see a million in your back yeah
did you see this the end yeah and I
screenshot
yeah over a million in my bank and I
just posted it yeah yeah and then he
came back and was like oh yeah well you
probably just got it from being a ripoff
landlord and I know this and it's like
you just cannot wait yeah and and and
and now like because people challenge me
on I've good on companies house and I
cut and unlike and I've explained this
over and over again yeah that when you
buy a house unless you trade it or buy
it through a company there's it's not
uncommon either and the thin people are
just so if people ask me how much I'm
earning because they want to be inspired
like you want you you go through my bank
statements of stuff I have inspiration
you know I want to be inspired but if
people want to do it to try and
desperately find a way of trying to
discredit you to then justify their own
excuses I'm not even interested in the
conversation
yeah I think it's just well been brought
up you know in the way look what the
people have been around and it's just
how it is
yeah and when I first met you and I was
very skeptical to begin with after the
crash course before I joined the Academy
I was like like show me your results
show me what you're doing you know but
you weren't afraid and I'm just getting
over that barrier you know I'm just
getting over it I think as well more
than anything is don't even look to me
like I'm teaching people to become
financially free okay you can look at me
and you can look at what I'm doing but
more than more importantly than that
look at my students like dome winners
Wednesday and see every single week
someone someone success story of
financial freedom or whatever look at
their stories because how successful I
am occupy I could be a billionaire but
that doesn't mean that I'm gonna help
you become successful yeah so more than
more important than anything is okay of
course I need to have been there done
that got the t-shirt myself which is
kind of obvious i own a castle you know
yeah but but is how my students getting
along and you're one of my students yeah
you didn't know what a mortgage was when
we met no you thought I mortgage or
something there was a test on two that
I've always liked a box in the corner
dice solo looking around where's this
mortgage that's so me so I talk to me
talk to me give me some good I want to
ask you a question going because you
asked me about finance let me ask you a
question yeah wait right yeah I've heard
you say before you want to be on the
Forbes list well I mean was it the dude
I think you'll be kind of cool to be on
to be on TV on on the Forbes list ah
what's your point but I wanna know when
buy when when your life that's ago when
you gonna hit that goal I don't even
actually know what you need to do to get
on I don't even lift so what's your next
goal you tell me what you what your next
goal is my next goal okay dude wow
you've put me on the spot yeah bro okay
my next goal right now I want to do two
deals this year in 2020 yeah make a
minimum of a million pounds clean profit
for me each deal okay that's my goal
this day and so my goal then is to be an
in on one of them those of you okay I've
just set myself and you go okay so how
you gonna do that that's X Y Z we'll
figure it out I'll figure it out I'll
fart we'll figure something out but
that's one of mine
I'm sure we can do it it's a sin for
love a podcast to a goal same session
that's good that's good also I said
another gone when I got here because by
the way where you live is like
phenomenal this house unbelievable have
you not been here before notice the
first time I've never had an invite well
welcome to my home thanks Richie never
had an invite
sees that inspiration yeah you know what
I own this house yes yeah no people you
know we were we were everywhere we live
yeah I rent this place and everything
sometimes people say like oh you just
ran it's like did I don't just rent like
I own a lot of properties I choose to
rent this as a commercial decision but
the rent on this house is not cheap you
know it's really expensive but it's
covered for my passive income quest then
what's the sameness rent where you live
and by where you rent yep that's what
it's a smarter way to do it yeah in not
in my opinion for me like where I sleep
and where I'm based and stuff it's like
a hotel almost like this place okay I'm
here I mean it's big enough to be a
hotel but I don't see this place is like
a douche it as a home but it's not a
forever home so how long do you think
you're gonna be here and where do you
see yourself moving to is there anywhere
like I'm in the process of getting and
getting another place already I'm
getting that I'll stay here
yeah I'm actually looking at apartments
in central London so I'll get like a
city alright the offices are based in
central London everything happens in
central London really yeah how come you
don't live closer to central London on
like 20 minutes why yarn-over what made
you think okay I'm not gonna actually
live in central London so I can walk out
but don't be at the offices I think it's
just because where I live like beckons
field it's just really peaceful I mean
even now all I can hear when I stop
talking is the birds outside and the
rain which was actually one of the
laptops on the side yeah so I think that
I think it's just peace yeah it's nice
you know what you actually achieve a lot
more when you and when when it when you
can put yourself in situations ways
peaceful that's where my thinking time
happens London is where I go to work
yeah and I want a pad in London I'm
looking at apartments and stuff but then
at home whenever a peaceful home that's
where I come up with a lot of the ideas
when you have you got like an ideas room
because you haven't even showed me
around yet I'll show you around after
okay so is there like a room in the
house we emeritus
sit down Yahoo's [ __ ] I've got an office
and stuff but it doesn't it's not even
like that it's just it's just wherever I
am I can be in the kitchen or the lounge
yeah just in a place of peace and I'm
just coming up with ideas and B if I'm
on holiday when I get back from holiday
then I'm like boom I got so many ideas
and then I'll go make it happen in
central London where people aren't I can
delegate everything and I can point
people and I can make it happen in
London and then I'll come back escape
into the choir and then go to go to town
with my notebook yeah it's interesting
there's kind of how I live my life he's
interested in have you got like a gym
here and stuff I have but he's just not
carried out yet right so gym room
okay slash Amelia's bedroom bedroom no I
just when she when she we worked really
late and I pretended it was a bedroom
and there was just a little mat on the
floor is this okay for you and she was
like yeah okay just a prank okay um so I
feel like I'm gonna my big day in this
podcast it's pretty yeah this is like
you own is gonna wins this is the Ricky
Mandel podcast um I saw some books on
the side in there yeah common was cooled
but what you reading in the minute I'm
really quite a lot do you know what I'm
reading at the moment actually I'm
reading a book about Vince McMahon WWE
yeah oh wow I think it's called death by
territories okay and it's about how WWF
and WWE will started and and and the
reason I'm interested in that is just
because it's a world I mean in the title
worldwide yeah any any organization that
can get that big and become that
worldwide interests me yeah so I'll
often read biographies of people you
know like Richard Branson you started
virgin you know Steve Jobs those types
of people and those kind of businesses
that have global impact really interests
me so I'm just studying convincement man
right now so do you do you just read or
do you watch as well I've read listen
watch
discuss yeah I'm reading a pretty cool
book is Grant Cardone
I am listening to on
on Amazon books whoever is its client
cardones I think it's good to survival
yeah yeah yeah great really good really
good because in life I think everything
sells mmm so you need to learn how to
sell even it even it's not just a
product it might be yeah but it might be
selling your your yourself to someone as
a brand you know selling your idea to
someone send an opportunity anything so
we just whilst I'd read it now cuz
everything sells okay everything and
everything is people property businesses
are people business yeah that you don't
get paid from property you get paid from
people that might live in the property
or bar as a property but if you don't
know how to communicate with people then
then you're not gonna get money what's
the best skill someone could have as a
person you know that you got
communication you can be a good
communicator you could be good at sales
what do you think maybe the top three
skills and assets someone should have
great question I think deal analysis is
really good like being able to analyze a
deal yeah and work out the numbers it's
a skill that I had to learn and I think
that's just basic maths so for instance
in property what's the rent
what's the value what's the return on
investment gonna be you know what's the
risk what's that all that deal analysis
stuffs really and I would have really
struggled with that yeah but we've like
the academy training stuff that just
makes it that part a whole lot easier
because it's actually simple yeah it's
very very simple you just have to know
what you've done
yeah you do you just have to do the
formula so knowing the formulas yeah and
everything I teach is all about formulas
anyway so knowing the formulas I think
that's a skill yeah
secondly would be I would say just more
rather than a skill more of an attitude
I think having an having an attitude of
of gratitude okay like where you just
are grateful and thankful yeah I think
that will serve you so well because I
mean I'm you know I'm run a company with
40 to 42 people in it across the across
the boards and the companies if I think
if I was like and entitled you don't
want any tired employees but you also
don't want an entitled manager yeah and
I think if you're like entitled and and
not grateful you just people are going
to resent you yeah
resent you it's a really bad thing even
tenants you don't want tenants to think
that you're a greedy landlord and just
the smallest things like just sending a
Christmas card and saying I appreciate
you as a tenant you know give us a shout
if it costs a pound and you can
systemize it and you mean it but having
the heart that what is just grateful for
for your staff and for your tenants and
for your colleagues and for your
trainers same with trainers like people
that men have mentored me like Simon
Zushi for instance he sort of started me
off in property he didn't do hoots in
terms of like you know like but but but
what he did do made it made it in his
mind it didn't it wasn't a lot but it
meant a lot to me yeah and if it wasn't
for his you know those few phone calls
and things that he helped me with in
ideas and those presentations that I
heard you know so now even today even
like 10 12 years later I'll still be
grateful I'll still honor him and people
that have anyone that's mentored me or
helped me whether it be family friends
mentors trainers you know all always all
of them be grateful for them and I think
it goes a long way now when I've got
students the students that honor me
let's say let's say I help someone and
then I see them just do a post of
recognition and stuff like that and they
honor me and they're grateful for me it
makes me want to do more yeah I'm
thinking oh man how can I go the extra
and I think in that spirit of gratitude
and honor and recognition I think he's
just so so powerful and ultimately even
self is just speaking because you give
but they're not selfish to speak in the
people that give more get more yeah and
that's just that's just I've been
there's different ways of looking at
like gratitude because I also know cuz I
studied law at Tony Robbins yeah and he
always says that the reason why the
first thing he does in the morning is he
does is Prime in and part of the prime
in is thinking of three things you're
grateful for and be and you truly get in
the present mode and you feel grateful
for them things and it sets you up for
the day and I was wondering when I was
looking at why worth being grateful
first me in the morning set you up for
the day because being grateful for these
free things takes five minutes and then
you've got the rest of the day but this
is the thing you can't be grateful and
sad at the same time
so if you live in a world where you're
constantly grateful you can't be sad
because it's completely opposite and you
can't feel two things that want to put
its two emotions at once so true so
living in a world where you're grateful
all the time it will eliminate the
sadness okay and people that are
ungrateful and all you know that's what
I see people you know on social media or
ever in that in their net complain and
all that [ __ ] and actually feeling it I
almost feel sad because because I know
if people of that yeah well they're sad
people you know you know I totally agree
so that's definitely a big for me that's
like really important being grateful and
and and and just having the good
attitude yeah a really long way and then
thirdly because you asked me three
things I would say he's been able to
negotiate a deal you know yeah yeah
what's a negotiate deal but if here's
the thing if you combine those three
skills boom here's why you negotiate a
good deal your hard negotiator United
negotiate you know the scripts not to
say but you do it from a position of
actually also wanting to help to the
person having a good attitude and we've
known your numbers yeah
you just can't not have a massive
business when you do those two things so
would you relate all of them free
obviously related all of them free
things to property yeah so to be says
anything just in life there's a free
things in lovely I've need marriage
having a business staff landlord
whatever you need to be grateful and
have a good attitude you need to go to
crunch numbers in the deal hmm and you
need to be able to negotiate even even
with family you need to negotiate I
wanna go show my to your girl after
negotiations in Hershey about you know
whether she keeps putting the bunny in
her mouth and it's actually causing her
problems right I don't want to have the
bunny so I want to take the bunny offer
but then I'll take the bunny offer but
then I'll give her something else you
feel like everything that you can apply
in property you commute everything can
be applied in real life as well
everything like being able to work out
the return on investment of a HMO isn't
gonna have a but this yeah yeah but but
but the general skills of negotiation
communication win
I want you to win I don't want you to
have the bun in your mouth yeah mess
your teeth up but at the same time I
don't we were all sad yeah the money not
a few but then I'll give you this
instead see I find you a really
knowledgeable person with lots of you've
got your property goals and you do your
property nee do you train in and your
that since that day I've met you you've
always been the kind of person that will
always give good advice so is there
anything else that you're thinking of
doing in the future
other than property in training dude I
know property - well like the thing is
if I try to advise on other stuff like
I've talked I just mentioned about
marriage and kids and I'm not the dude
to go to advice when it comes to that
corners right I'm all right
you know yeah when it comes to health
for instance I'm trying to I'm trying to
get in shape and I'm doing stuff I don't
want to teach that because I don't I
don't consider myself an expert in those
areas yeah and and and I might be good I
might offer some advice to my friends or
whatever but when it comes to actually
doing like training and teaching people
people looking up to me as a role model
in those areas mm-hmm but when it comes
to making money and investing money as a
property entrepreneur dude
no one beats me I'm the best so and and
I feel that I can I can speak with
complete confidence and conviction and
authority because I've done it like a
million times people look but I'll often
hear people say well how do you know
he's the best but it's that's kind of
speak for themselves how many people own
wounds on a Wednesday well we've got
people every week every single week yeah
you know I sat back the other week and
that because I saw those are two two
ladies from where are they
is it - Emma and Katie yes smashing
enough for every week there's new people
on Windows on a Wednesday live shows
like I've sat there now for there wasn't
any doubt but I do think myself it's
just ever gonna run out because I
actually can't see it happening though
we're at least permanently adjoining us
crash once every week we're helping at
the academy trains and the amount of
people that this is changing like this
isn't this isn't gonna stop day that I
can't get people on Windows Wednesday is
the day that I'll have to quit training
never I don't think as long as I'm
training it's never gonna happen because
the training works and I think that when
is Wednesday as well
it's just the people that want to come
on the show yeah like us camellia we've
got people that are financially free
we've got people making ten grand a
month and they go I'd rather keep though
I'd rather keep my head low and I'm like
I mean okay sometimes I get it I don't
agree with it because I think that you
should once you become successful I my
makeup is that you and then have a duty
and a responsibility to share that with
other people yeah and I also think that
it's good branding it's good for me
because I love people sharing their
stories on my channel it gives my
channel content yes see people say to be
sending out what's your YouTube videos
they're amazing it's not my youtube
channel the YouTube channel is our
YouTube channel yeah you know it we're
firstly we're an immediate team secondly
only half of the videos of me
yeah half I'm interviewing other people
I'm chatting with and from a branding
perspective that's incredible yeah
because we've got like 150 thousand yeah
I know just from my one is on a
Wednesday my mailing list of my
investors this that that took off yeah
just from that so I think it'd be it's
not obviously people would like to do
things their own way if they don't go on
whatever whatever but if people have an
opportunity to actually go on their the
brat from life from my experience I'm
sure auntie Jane like everyone has been
unable to agree from a branding
perspective one of the best things you
could do I think so because you've spent
a lot of time and money getting your
YouTube well a lot of time I know that
and money because we have to pay video
yeah like it costs a lot of time and
money to see these microphones are
expensive the lights are expensive but
you know what we don't have a problem
getting people on we're friends and that
it's easy because we've got I mean we've
got so many people becoming successful
in property from the trainers so oh and
the meal the other day yeah by the way
that was so good what happened well
we're like we when you're on one of them
Wednesday there's this groups and
networking community in staff and we use
this we had a message saying we're gonna
meet up in London for a meal you all
paid for you know it's on us so I
thought
sounds good let's go and you know what
it was it wasn't it was a networking
meal and we sat down and stuff but the
biggest thing I took from it was just
the positivity in the room like everyone
stood up and shared a little bit about
what they've done where it was Menna be
okay everyone's gonna share up and send
it and [ __ ] son of a share a little bit
what they've done over the last year or
six months whatever maybe but it didn't
actually end up being that because no
one really wanted to talk about what
they've achieved they wanted to talk
about more how other people are doing
and how good it is to be around these
people
yes everyone succeeded there and
everyone's done well but it was more
about look how positive this room knows
amazing in that Rona
I think it was a 32 I think yeah I said
put your hand up you thought next before
everyone's financially free you have
been invited to the dinner if they
weren't financially for it but then I
said put your hand up if you make it
it's 10 grand a month and the third just
over a third of the room there was like
12 people to put the hand up which is
really high because we're like trained
people like at the crash course and
stuff even on the Academy the goal is
not to become really rich yeah it's a no
come be a millionaire or come and make
you know ten grand a month what I say is
come and make a few rounder month
replace your income and become
financially free yeah so the you have
time because the best things in life are
free but males what cost the earth you
can call the time to enjoy them so buy
your time back but what people do is
they end up like you now you say you set
to make six figures yeah they become
financially free and then they just step
it up step it up step it up step yeah
but it's because once you get a taste
for being financially free and you get a
taste of a few thousand pounds a month
it's not the snowball you just want to
get more and more yeah you know because
it will help with whatever your mission
is yeah you know it's like I don't know
what's compared it to you but that's
kind of what I'm gonna indict it yeah
because it feeds what what your what
your purpose is yeah you know and you
know that if you go from starting with
nothing like you don't know like me I
started no property knowledge or nothing
if I know I can make a few thousand
pounds in property which I did then
what's to stop me making ten thousand on
do be stupid not to if you had to advise
your two year younger self as you're
getting into property a top three things
go first thing would be education
because you can't do about the education
you can but you'll make costly mistakes
you make mistakes with education where
you make costly mistakes without the
education yeah second thing is implement
because you can get the education if you
don't implement the new education is
wasted so you have to implement to get
the results and the third thing is just
be consistent you know if you're going
to
if you're going to get education you're
going to implement you have to be
persistent to see to hit the end of real
simple advice but so powerful and so -
yeah and I think you know me and your
people where people can look at us being
inspired because we didn't come from
wealthy backgrounds we didn't get super
educated at university we just three
things we got the training we took
action
we were consistent and I'm proud of what
you've done man I really I'm really
grateful for you as well see you giving
so much value in the group yeah I see
you on stage sharing from a position of
love and I'm just stoked
I'm so excited and it's great to become
friends with my students I'm glad to say
yeah good friend and no okay so for
anyone listen to this I'm gonna give a
little advice and then you I want to say
firstly if you're watching on YouTube
please smash the like button subscribe
and drop a nice comment for Ricky Ricky
gets enough bad comments please give him
some nice ones if you're listening on
the podcast lead a podcast review
anything to add to that Ricky if you
listening to this you listening to it
for a reason so do summon get to a crash
course keep watching the videos keep
being inspired keep learning yes and
just take action Manuel is something you
want to come to a crash course it is
www.prophecyinthenews.com at UK see
there god bless have yourself a
wonderful evening
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]